the broadcast is now starting all
attendees are in listen only mode hey
everybody it's Mike from order flows and
I'm going to get started in about a
minute you know it's still uh we still
got about a minute before it hits uh one
o'clock Chicago time I know it's kind of
an odd time to uh do a a special do a
webinar basically
um and you know so I want to give people
you know time to make it on call
um the ones that that signed up and you
know just a few things yes this will be
recorded and I'll be sending out the
recording uh it'll probably be posted on
my YouTube channel as well so you can
check it out and you know if you have
questions I'm going to put some time
aside at the end to answer questions so
um you know I'm going to try not to get
sidetracked you know sometimes it's easy
to get sidetracked in in uh you know
training like this
um if my if I keep looking at questions
and again you know there's a few links
that I put in the chat I'm going to talk
about them once once we We Begin you
know basically one is to get started
with go charting uh another one another
Link in there is for the user guide for
order flows Trader on go charting the
third one is sort of instructional
videos on each of the order flows Trader
indicator and the last one is as a
trading course that I created for go
charting on order flow specifically
using go charting so you can you can
check that out as well but I'll talk
about that once we get started I'm just
uh waiting until we hit right on top of
the hour then I'll get started here so
again
it's uh
it's uh it's one of those things where
um you know this has been a long uh
project that we've been working on for
you know a good part of this year and
I'm just excited to get it out so let me
just go through one or two last minute
checks on my end then I'll get started
okay so it looks like everything is fine
on my end and I'll get started here
Chris uh hey nice to see you here you
know we got actually a quite a big
audience today and you know I'm excited
about uh the order flows Trader
appearing on go charting uh because you
know go charting is a web-based platform
and so basically you could access it and
do your analysis uh basically from
anywhere without having to install it on
a desktop like um you know like
ninjatrader or Sierra charts and you
know it's it's quite nice because the
you know I use a Samsung fold phone
right so I got a bigger screen and you
know I I look at the footprint chart
when I'm out so if I got to go out
during the day you know I'm away from my
desk it's quite nice to have all the the
tools there and you know just a real
quick question right now you know people
have asked me is this going to replace
the ninjatrader version no the ninja
Trader version is still
um you know still in existence it's
still going to be supported it's you
know this is an alternative to the
ninjatrader version right because again
you know some people use a Mac or
you know some people you know sometimes
they're going to travel or something and
they just want to have access to keep in
touch with the market and the order flow
while they're traveling this is a great
uh
yeah what's the word not alternative but
you know a compliment rather to the
ninjatrader version and you know the one
nice thing about the guys at go chart
you know they understand order flow
right they they are big Believers in
order flow they're not just um you know
a software company that says hey you
know what let's put a charting software
out there oh and you know order flow is
is hot right now so let's add in a
footprint chart no they understand order
flow and its importance and they
actually have a lot of tools which I'll
discuss
um once we begin and
so let's just uh sort of jump right into
it here and again it's I'm going to try
and keep this as short you know it is
Sunday
um but it'll probably go at least an
hour so uh strap in so again brief
disclaimer
um you know we're all adults here right
we know that trading does involve risk
and you shouldn't be trading with
basically your rent money like you know
sometimes I see people going through oh
Mike you know I lost my job and uh I got
like Severance for three months I need
to learn how to how to trade to
supplement that don't put yourself under
that gun
um you know find uh
you know trading the markets are there
for hundreds of years they'll be there
in the future as well so you know take
your time and learn Don't force yourself
to do it right don't trade with money
that you can't afford to lose
and again you know I that that's
basically just comes down to
understanding that you know Trading
does involve risk so go charting okay if
you haven't already checked it out go to
gocharting.com right that's what their
homepage looks like now
with go charting right what are the
benefits well they have specialized
tools right they have charting and
indicators tailored specifically for
order flows Trader and that's why you
know there was a big uh we made a big
push to get my tools on there because
you know
my tools are I like to think they're
cutting edge you know I like that I've
developed a lot of tools that have been
copied by all the other software vendors
but the problem is they don't teach
people how to use them like oh you know
here's this tool okay well okay fine you
go to any other trading platform right
you'll see there's hundreds if not
thousands of indicators but then there's
there's no instruction on how to use it
you know I provide that instruction
um with go charting
and go charting is easy to use as a very
intuitive interface which is optimized
for visualizing and analyzing order flow
right so it's going to lower the
learning curve right especially if
you're new to order flow
um it's a it's very easy to use you know
some softwares is very clunky and you
know you make a change and this changes
that changes the next thing you know the
chart you're looking at five minutes
you know five minutes earlier it looks
completely different and you're lost and
for me this is the strongest thing right
it's a web-based access so as a
web-based platform
you know go charting allows accessing
charts and trading from anywhere without
install so you don't have to install
anything to your phone or to your
desktop or anything you know and you
know you don't have to worry about
machine IDs changing when there's a bios
upgrade
um you just log into it right which is
nice so you don't have to worry about
any of that stuff
um you know you change your PC then you
got to download it again so like like
these other softwares right you gotta do
that and you gotta enter in all your
details Etc you know with go charting
it's all right there for you you just
just log in
um from anywhere there's education right
they have uh go turning focuses on order
flow trading through videos guys
webinars such as this and they have a
community right there active Community
they have a big Discord group
um where you go in and you know they
even got a special section now for the
order flows uh stuff and
it's got lower costs right I mean you
look at some of these platforms
you got to pay a lot of money for you
know some platforms are thousands of
dollars and go charting is is not like
that so
I put all these links in the chat and
you know I want to email them out later
I just want to go over these really
quick before we sort of start jumping
into everything now
for the month of August the order flows
Trader is free on go charting but you
know when you think of it as a free
trial right now okay eventually it's
going to go to a paid subscription a
monthly one but quite small you know
relative to
um you know I see other softwares that
just have a basically a footprint and
actually have like two or three of my
tools on there and they're charging like
200 a month we're gonna be charging much
much lesser than that
um all right now it looks like it's
going to be 49 a month for all the tools
I'll be talking about today and if you
want to get the CME data
at a discounted price
you can get it for
ten dollars for the first month but you
got to sign up through this link now
it's gocharting.com this one right here
okay and again it's going it's in the
chat but I'm going to email it out to
you guys because if you don't go through
this link then you're going to pay 35 so
it's an extra 25 so you're saving 25 on
the data for the first month now it will
recur after the first month at the
normal 35 dollars but again if you're
testing out a software you want to check
it out in real time I couldn't I wasn't
able to get them to offer it for free
but you know so they are taking a small
loss on the data feed so you can try
this uh order flows Trader
package okay but again you know when
you're testing software ideally you want
to test it on real-time data and you
know see how it how it looks under say
the microscope but you know with
real-time data now
I created a user guide specifically for
the order flows Trader on go charting
okay so that's the second link again all
these links are in the chat and they
will be emailed to you
um I have a special page for
um with instructional videos on each of
the indicators that are from order
fillestrator that are on go charting so
you could understand you know when you
want to use them what they mean their
significance Etc because you know it's
one thing having tools but if you don't
have any instruction on
why they're created
you're probably not going to use them
right like I said you know every
charting platform out there in existence
has hundreds if not thousands of
indicators you don't use them because
you don't know anything about them
that's why I have this special page that
explains the indicators and how to use
them and
earlier this year I made a special order
flow trading course it's uh you know
it's a short course it's probably before
modules five modules I think
um you know it's sort of uh introduction
to order flow and it's a nice course you
can get access to that for free it's uh
and again it's ghost charting based
right so it's based on you know what
you're gonna be looking at on go
charting and that's that's the link it's
kind of long that's why I put the links
in the chat below
um and
you know there's a special section for
chat
okay that you got to go to to find it
I'm gonna also
you know somebody asked uh really
a question on how does they can't see
the links but let me just uh
I'm gonna answer that question really
quick
there I'm gonna send it to all in the
question section there's a question
section and there's a chat section of
um go to webinar right so you got to
find it if I gotta scroll down a little
bit
but um
yeah so that's uh just really quick
before I jump into the actual
um
you know I'll call it the actual goal
charting platform I just want to go over
really quick what some of these you know
what the order post Trader has in terms
of order flow what go charting has in
terms of order flow analysis right so
that you know you could really
comprehend
sort of the magnitude of you know what
you're getting with go charting so with
the order flow is Trader right we have
the exhaustion print imbalance reversal
ratio slingshot point of control
um we Market weakness sequencing Market
sweeps prominent important controls
um zero prints inverse balance multiple
imbalance buying selling Tails thin
prints
um on go charting they call their
footprint the cluster chart okay and
when I when I show you this it's going
to sort of blow your mind in a bit but
you can actually have you know you could
have a right side a left side you put
different data on the right side of the
bar versus the left side but then they
also got
um you know point of control markers
volume point of control you can extend
the point of control value areas you
know you can even see where the previous
point of control was the engulfing value
areas B web marker volume marker Delta
markers cumulative Delta Delta
Divergence now they're Delta Divergence
this one here is slightly different than
my Delta Divergence but I'll explain
that the cot marker high low marker
unfinished auction
um then you get into the bar statistics
right this is an overlooked area for a
lot of Traders right they don't want to
get caught up in things like Delta and
things like that but there's a lot of
information there
and you can see you can get all these
metrics in here
I don't use them all I use you know the
ones that are that I find useful for my
own trading but you know you could have
like ball you know I look at volume
Delta Max Delta Min Delta cumulative
Delta
um
Delta percentage but you know you could
have like the V web you could have you
know what the buying B whack was versus
selling beware
um you know all sorts of stuff right the
volumes the percentage of volumes
um you know the actual trades that were
taking place all sorts of information
okay so that's great so again there's a
lot of tools available on go charting
analyzing order flow requires a nuanced
approach that goes beyond the surface
level interpretation it's just price
right you want to look under the hood so
to speak right it's going to necessitate
a thorough understanding of underlying
Dynamics right that's why having bar
statistics is very useful because those
underlying Dynamics Drive Market
behavior and by delving into the
intricacies of order flow you know
Traders can uncover valuable insights
that will inform their investment
decisions basically your trading so
that's why there are many different
order flow tools on go charting whoops
okay all right so
um where am I here all right let me pull
up uh go charting really quick
find my mouse where's it
okay so here we are go charting okay now
it might be a little hard to see my
mouse now
sign in okay let me uh
let me log out here okay I've got my own
login but you know there was I didn't
get a question you know how do you how
do you log in right simply right you
click login it's going to ask you to
sign in if you don't have an account you
gotta create an account okay now
if you are going to create an account
you gotta decide which data you want
okay so like for example they have India
Forex and crypto
um
you know that's fourteen dollars a month
that's that's not much
um this is if you're doing it annually
if you do it monthly it's a little
higher price right build monthly CME
premium is 35 but if you use that link
that I put in the chat
it's gonna when you go through the whole
checkout process right you're going to
see
um buy now I think it's going to ask you
to create an account it's still going to
show 35. when you get to the final page
it'll show the discounted price
okay and uh you know I made a video on
crypto yesterday it's it's a great way
to if you like to analyze crypto um but
anyway let me just log in here real
quick so again it's got my saves
information already
okay then you just uh you know click
simple click on products
now my default right shows as Nifty but
I'm going to talk about uh e-mini's ES
U right I just type it up here in the
upper left hand corner
right I open up the sort of the chain
here and I find which contract I want to
look at right September contract
okay so now you can see it
here right you got to expand it out a
bit right click on the bottom now this
is the chart that I use okay so I just
want to show you how to add it uh we'll
go through from scratch okay so for
example if you know say it's the first
time
you use
no charting okay you're not going to
have a lot of this stuff on your charts
it's going to look like this right it's
a simple bar chart right e-mini one
minute chart
okay and you want to add order flow what
what some people you have to go through
there's a little process you got to go
through right if you just click on here
add order flows Trader right you're not
going to see anything what you have to
do is you have to add the cluster chart
first okay so let me just take this off
and take it through the setup right so
if you're at a basic Candlestick chart
you go to charts
the bottom one here cluster okay that
brings up your footprint chart
okay now to add the order flows Trader
then you click on
order flows Trader okay and it's going
to add the different things now let's
just uh take a look here at the settings
now
expand this up a bit but first let me
just uh I don't want to confuse people
so I'm going to disable a lot of these
things here
Okay so
then on the cluster chart
um disabled open this auction
be wet marker
that off
so
okay
this is sort of your basic footprint
chart
right you got your volume on the bid
volume on the offer you know your point
of control in the middle you see the
buying imbalance you can see you're
selling a balance
Etc you know which is basically a basic
footprint chart now
the important thing to remember with go
charting is this layers up here in the
upper
right hand corner okay because that's
basically where you're going to make a
lot of the changes to
your footprint so what you want to do
what I like to do right this is the
chart that I like okay and you know if
you're interested in sort of my
chart
um
message me and and I can I'll send you
the
the URL so you can open it up
I like a double
cluster chart right so I have volume on
the bid volume on the offer right you
you could do a single chart which just
shows
um
you know just the volume
right okay but I like to look at the
information right now you could
choose what you want to look at trades
buy trades sell trades sell trade
percentage volume Etc Delta Delta
percentage bid and the ask so since I'm
using both a double-sided cluster a
right side and a left side I know that
the left side right
is going to be
sorry this is the left side the left
side is going to be what aggressive
sellers are selling into the bid so
that's why I have it as cell volume and
the right side is where aggressive
Traders are buying from the passive
sellers right so that's why it's by
volume you know if you want to get you
know fancy you can even do like bid ask
on both one side right you got to expand
it up so you could fit it there you can
see the volumes and maybe you want to
have you know Delta
on the other side you know it's
it's nice to look at but again it's all
about what you want to see on your chart
and what you're used to
um looking at okay
but for now I'll just keep it as uh
sort of the normal cell volume and buy
volume which is what most of us are used
to
um now imbalances okay
all right you can see this red
thing is it one thing you know if you
want to change the color of the text
of the footprint it's this one where it
says text okay
you can change that there you just click
on it to uh change the color I like
black black on white right when you know
some people
like to have a black background or
something like that but you know when
you read a book it's black text on a
white background so in my opinion
footprint is best used there now
imbalances okay this was a change that I
asked them to make because before you
know what they had was
a thing where it would highlight the
imbalance in the bar okay
a certain color like in this case orange
but
most of us are used to looking at the
actual number right being the volume
being printed red for solid and balance
and
um blue for a buying imbalance okay so I
don't uh I don't necessarily use that
um I don't use the color here's where
you can change you could use a ratio or
a fixed number
it's fixed numbers based on volume but
the ratio this is where you're going to
adjust it here right that's 400 that'd
be four to one okay it's in a percentage
if you want to use a thousand you'd use
you know if you want to use 10 to 1
you'd change it to
a thousand okay if you want to use 300
you change it to 300 I use 400.
okay now should show support resistance
zones okay
that would be for stacked imbalances
this is their stacked imbalance one they
call it uh support resistance zones you
could adjust the
um
the amount right so here's stack buying
and balance zone of two up here
again that's for two if it's three is
nothing showing okay so turn it off
um a couple other things again you could
play around with a lot of these I want
to control marker
okay if you click on that it just makes
it the whole price now
one of the things with uh go charting is
you could adjust the opacity on a lot of
things right so you choose the color and
then down here there's sort of this
Checker area that's the opacity so if
you want to you know have it colored
and then but still read underneath you
can just change the opacity okay
but uh
I don't uh
what is it here I don't I don't need
that volume point of control
oops
again you know
if you want to have that on there you
can adjust
whatever color you want how strong you
want
right PLC marker you want to extend it
out basically draw the line out right
it's good for
um
you know seeing point of controls where
they don't trade back into the next bar
right because oftentimes it's going to
trade back to it right generally point
of control is going to act as support or
resistance right on a on a rising market
or a falling market right you can see
here or it's just leaving it abandoned
as the market sells off and let's just
go back up here
okay so I'll close that down
um
or am I here previous point of control
all right if you want to know where the
previous point of control was as the
next bar is forming I mean obviously you
could see it you know on the chart but
if you want to have a visual
representation of it be printed out
there it's right there value area right
to me this is an important one
you just take that off here
value area is very important as a Trader
right you want to know where where value
is okay so you could you know you could
adjust the colors it's very flexible
um if you want to extend it out extend
value area extension right is you want
to be looking for those value areas that
are potentially going to act as support
or resistance okay
right this is
right I can see there's none here
but when you see them right you can see
how the market sort of Trades back into
it and trying to decide if it's going to
hold or not you know here right
beautiful one went up came right back in
this value area held and then it had a
nice move up
um what am I here
okay
view app marker right it will print the
view app price level on your chart here
you can see each of these levels and the
price in the middle that's where view
app is right
volume marker just prints it above or
below Delta same thing
cumulative Delta
Now Delta Divergence okay let me just
put up the Delta marker
Delta Divergence what it's going to do
right you can see there's this red line
this blue line okay and the whole point
of it is this bar is a green candle with
negative Delta
this bar is a red candle with positive
Delta
and it's just highlighting to you that
hey you know what you have a Divergence
between
price action and what Delta is okay and
that's important in my mind at turning
points potential turning points or swing
highs or swing lows right not
necessarily in the middle of moves
although sometimes you know if you're in
the middle of a move you want to have
some sort of clue that there's
supportive buying or aggressives or
resistant selling taking place but it'll
draw that line there for you so it's
just a visual reference of you know what
we do have some Divergence coming in
here
um CLT marker just show it right above
the bar right below the bar
um high low marker
basically the distance of the bar right
this
distance from high to low in picks
unfinished auctions all right it'll draw
that
line out from the top of the bar if
there's unfinished auction 14 and 85 122
117 so here's a line on top here's a
line on the bottom okay now let's jump
into the actual order flows Trader
platform so what they've done actually
is they've Incorporated the value errors
in the past they didn't have the value
areas on here as part of their
Main
cluster chart but it's it's really such
an important part of my trading
um so I'm happy to see that they put it
in there okay
now exhaustion prints right now what an
exhaustion print is for those of you
that don't know is it shows when the
last buyer has bought in an up move
or the last seller sold in a down move
basically the buying is exhausted on the
move up there's no more interest in
buying and the market generally will
naturally
drop right conversely
did a down move right the selling is
exhausted there's no more selling
interest
and Mark is going to begin to rise
because there's still that buying
interest you know in the two-way auction
there's just the imagine it is the
buying interest or the selling interest
is removed from the market and
you can actually set the threshold let
me just turn off the value area
extension here okay so you can see here
right exhaustion print exhaustion print
exhaustion print exhaustion print where
you know this can be very useful
is you know if you're coming into
you know a low or swing low you're
making a swing low and the market starts
to move up right what like here right
right we came down nicely right then
we're just sort of forming this bottom
this nice rounded bottom start going up
okay well
if this Market is going to go lower
right you still want to see some strong
selling taking place right but if you're
getting at the bottom of this bar just
three contracts so the sellers are done
right they're not interested in moving
this Market any lower and you get a nice
move up right so look for these at swing
highs or swing lows or even in moves
right to just sort of basically tell you
that you know what we've got some
momentum that's building and
um you know Traders aren't interested in
really selling anymore uh so the next
one imbalance reversal okay so imbalance
reversal is basically a sign of uh
trap Traders okay and what it's going to
do okay you can see I don't know if you
can see that look up here
make these two boxes here
okay turn it off turn it on right the
box is there is it's basically telling
me that right up here you have some trap
Traders right look where it's coming in
right right up here
and then the market sells off right
let's see if I could find one sort of a
bullish one there's a bullish one down
here we just came down made a new low by
what one two ticks right hit that double
bottom here but I know that down here
Traders are getting trapped right
Trader's probably getting trapped here
just not kicking off that signal but
again from this low right we you know
two bars later we went higher but
eventually we went you know much higher
okay
now
just what am I here let's turn this off
ratios overflow ratios okay
drink some water here
okay now ratios is something that you
know is sort of the whole reason why I
created the order flows Trader in the
past because I used to do these in my
head
and you know there's basically a ratio
it reads the or analyzes the order flow
and if the order flow is bullish or
bearish it puts a number below the bar
here or above the bar
if it's bearish if it's going to be
above a red candle if it's bullish it's
going to be below the bar right you can
see right here Point okay what happened
here
you know 132 it's going to be this blue
number 50.
okay 64 38 and you know really basically
it's just telling you there's either
price support or Price resistance and
it's been it's important part of my own
trading uh ever since
you know by the last 10 years and that's
why I created the order flows Trader
initially is because I was using just a
plain orderful footprint chart in the
past and I would just calculate the
stuff in my head and I wanted to have it
on a chart so that I could take
advantage of it
um
without having to calculate it right
just visually see it slingshot point of
control okay
is basically it's a point of control
uh
setup here so we can see a couple here
bearish air bearish here but you know
bullish up here
um it analyzes the point of control
relative to
um you know previous bars uh point of
control it basically can signal a
directional move
okay
in this case still obviously this one
didn't work out next bar didn't even go
any lower right when I see a
slingshot point of control I'm looking
for the next bar to start trading higher
right before I take a trade it's not
that oh I got a bullish
slingshot point of control I gotta
immediately get long no you still need
to follow through order flow right you
had a little bit here and Mark it went
sideways this one definitely you would
not uh be taking
now Market weakness is sort of the next
one I want to talk about
a market weakness and you could see I
don't know if you saw that little Arrow
Flash right there okay if I turn it on
right you can see it down there what
it's telling me is you know based off of
the order flow
is you know areas where the market is
exhibiting weakness after a move up or
down okay so for example
um you know this Market has been moving
down
down down and it gets down to this low
area where
when it it gets kind of tricky because
you know when people think of Market
weakness they think oh the Market's weak
it's got to sell off really what it's
measuring is the intensity of the
selling that's taking place right that
aggressive selling that's taking place
moving the market down has weakened all
right so this is a reversal signal and
you can see the market reverse from here
back up right you can see the market was
selling off a little bit pulled back
here Market weakness Market went back up
um you know one here right now here we
hit a high sold off a little bit came
back up Market weakness right here this
we call that magenta down arrow okay
look
right you see it's off no it's on okay
and you know Market started to come off
a little bit they're sort of trading
sideways for the most part before
eventually started coming off and then
this here and here Okay so
it's you know it's a sign now sometimes
what people want to do is they want to
put everything on their chart all at
once they get oh I got all these tools
I'm going to use them all at once no
um you really want to use the ones that
are going to help your Trading
because you know everyone sometimes
people throw everything up on there and
they're like okay
you know make it work it's like you know
sometimes you get
all the ingredients for your your recipe
and you know people expect that they're
going to be a Master Chef well you still
gotta use it completely correctly so
next one I want to talk about is uh
sequencing okay
this is bullish sequencing so again
under the layers tab here right this is
where you're going to be able to adjust
everything right off on whoops right Hey
where's my bullish sequencing here
okay right off on right here okay this
is bullish sequencing what sequencing
does is
it
analyzes the order flow Okay so
yeah if you ever looked at a dome right
or the depth of markets right you
understand what the order book is and
there's what we call a solidified order
book right and a solidified order book
is one in which
there's more volume at each level either
on the way up or on the way down okay
because most of the time you know order
book has
you know it has volumes at different
levels but it's varying right it's not
like sequentially more and more and more
but when she starts being sequentially
more and more and more oftentimes what
you have is you know someone trying to
put pressure on the market but when
there's a bullish sequencing someone is
coming through and lifting subsequent
higher volume offers
in sequence okay
and it's generally a bullish signal will
be generated
um you know let's find a bearish
here's a bearish one here right so
bullish one here bearish one here and
again what you when you're trading and
sequencing
um it's not something that is going to
all of a sudden turn the market from the
low all the way up to new highs of the
day or anything like that you you really
want to watch the follow through order
flow because what you have is a strong
Trader coming through here usually
pretty quick hitting this bid hitting
this bid hitting this bid hitting this
bid and hitting this bit each level for
more and more volume
until it's finally cleared and you're
looking for continuation right for the
market to keep going just as you know
this one here
you don't get that continuation in the
next bar right next bar just goes inside
right here you get a little bit of
continuation next bar so it's going
higher and you get a nice pop it's it's
a nice
um Trading
signal for the near term right with
order flow
you're reading what's happening in the
market right now so you want to take
advantage of what's happening in the
market you know right now basically
right and take advantage of it when it
comes in and uh and profit from it so
a sweep okay Market sweeps
now what this tells you is areas of
potential Market sweeping activity okay
when there's maybe a big strong buyer
coming through or a strong seller coming
through you know right here
okay and what it's doing is telling you
that someone swept through this this
area here someone swept through this
area here and again it's nice for
um
you know immediate moves right to
understand that hey you know what you
got a big aggressive seller taking place
or a big aggressive buyer taking place
now the next one uh let's see
Prominent Point of control okay this is
you know one of my favorites
and there are ways to trade this that
you know I I talk about in a lot of my
videos okay so again with go charting
right if you scrunch the chart it's
going to compress it okay I like to sort
of keep it up so I see the prices at
each level so I get a true
identification of you know where the
point of control is right once you start
scrunching up small it's going to change
you can change the Integrity of your
chart so I like to keep it normal okay
right like this
here so
I can see here Prominent Point of
control Prominent Point of control
Prominent Point of control
these are bearish ones right they're
magenta if they were blue that'd be
bullish but you can see here I got one
two three
and then the market has this nice drop
off from you know 80 all the way down
into you know this is what 73 this is 74
pulls back up starts working its way
back down with more bearish prominent
pointed controls now a Prominent Point
of control
is a point of control that matters right
every bar has a point of control it's
simply the price with the most volume
and
but you have to take point of controls
in context of the overall Market Okay so
you can see certain point of controls
are going to be acting as resistance
resistance resistance resistance right
resistance potentially support here
potentially supports breaking down
immediately you know if you're looking
at support you're not going to trade
right through it in the next bar
but that's what um you know Prominent
Point of controls are these are a very
important part of my own trading okay
and I love the ones that are not tested
in the next bar
right I know guys ever since I first
released this department point of
control concept back in 2016.
they built their whole trading plans
around training with prominent important
controls okay
so it's something you know at a minimum
you should look into right if there's
one thing people sometimes people ask me
what's the one thing I should focus in
on
on order flow well
there's several one things right that
you can sort of build a trading plan
around and and that's one of them from
an important controls now zero print
okay now honestly in a market like uh
e-minis that trades strong volume uh you
might not get many zero prints I don't
know if there's any even in here
this is on Fridays
uh
Friday session
okay this is a zero print right here
right is this this just basically
highlighted me there's a zero on the top
offer side of the bar or if it's a red
candle if it's a green candle it would
be on the bottom
mid side of the bar let me just pull up
another Market because I said on e-minis
you don't get a lot of them during the
day
but again like I said you know not
everybody just trades e-minis right A
lot of people trade currencies okay so
you can see here
zero print zero print zero print and the
Market's going down
um generally on the market that's going
up let me just uh
in a bit and make it
a bigger chart like uh
maybe if
a five minute chart here
you can see the zero print coming in
right here
Bend this up here
to go all right this is worse
I don't know what I did here aha
is bullish zero Prince
it's another bullish zero print
okay so you can see them on you know
Market set other markets besides just uh
minis right here's a bearish one right
in here here's a couple bullish ones
coming in down here zero print the one
nice thing about go charting which I
like to do sometimes is I just like to
keep the candle I've got whatever some
of the tools that I'm looking at
um showing on on here as if sometimes
you guys get a little tired looking at a
actual footprint but I know that it's
happening
zero prints coming in here zero prints
coming in here right
just you know for a quick glance that's
something you can do let me just go back
to uh
Minis
okay so again guys I'll get to your
questions uh afterwards uh it's not
right now
inverse imbalance now inverse imbalance
is
it's a sign of potentially trapped
Traders okay it's not a definite sign of
trap Traders so
let's go here okay so sometimes
you know
Traders get a little excited you know
doing it with their aggressive buying
and their aggressive selling
um and
yeah you want to be
clued in on it now with you know you'll
see some of these bars here right if we
were to make it a little smaller like
here's a sign here here's a sign here
there's a sign here one here one here
right this is uh let me just show you I
turn it off
right
in versus like those little
triangles disappeared now what is meant
the way it's meant to be used is that
swing highs swing lows it's a potential
Turning Point okay
if a Market's just going sideways and
you see it coming in like here right
you just got to ignore it because the
Market's going sideways you know really
you're looking for inflection points in
the market right where you know here
right we come up to a swing high right
here you're still one tick off a swing
low yeah I mean the market is going down
we got one here and here but really
that's not you know how it's meant to be
you want to be making a low making a low
making a low making a low making a low
giving you some signs that hey you know
what we got a base forming in here
Traders are getting trapped in the
markets
okay
now let's move on here uh
multiple imbalances
okay
you see here this Bar's got multiple
imbalances it's a purple color there
okay see that turn off turn on
turn off
turn on I don't want to confuse you here
let me just turn off
this uh
I don't know if the value area is here
okay so
right here multiple buying imbalances in
the bar one two three all right we all
are familiar with stacked imbalances but
there's times where there are
imbalances in a bar that are not stacked
neatly on top of each other and you've
got a lot does that mean they're not
important because they're not stacked no
of course not they're still important
here you got two that's stacked but then
you got another one up here so I know
there's aggressive buying spread out
through this bar
okay
now here's one two three that's a
stacked one there
you stack multiple selling imbalances
right there mark in this case just went
sideways
so again you know and if you're using
400 to 1
right whatever you have your imbalance
ratio set at here if you're going to use
you know 300
it might be different okay if you're
going to use you know a thousand
it's going to be different all right
but I use 400
oops
Okay so
that is multiple imbalances now buying
and selling tails
okay
buying a selling tales on e-mini's
is not something you see a whole heck of
a lot it's more prevalent in other
markets
um
that have a bit more volatility and
basically it's bad structure in the
market
let's say badge structure but uh sort of
poor structure let's see if there's any
even on NASDAQ on this day what am I
looking at a one minute chart
okay here I gotta open it up a bit
so you can see right here
this is bearish this is bearish this is
bearish as bullish
what it is is there's no counter trade
here right you have what's happened is
you know strong seller down into the
bottom of the bar the market snaps back
just as
you know up here right Market opened up
traded higher
and then you got no
basically you had like I don't know how
to describe it uh
think of it like
like in order to stop getting triggered
and popping up in here right you know
maybe a stop for someone you know most
of us we just trade relatively small
size you know for us you know 10 Lots
would be big but you know for you know a
regular institutional Trader at a bank
you know 50 Lots is nothing you know
just hit the buy button by 50.
that market or whatever or buy it up you
know how many ticks and that just clears
everything out up there and then the
market immediately reverts back down
right so that's actually even though you
had a buyer come in here and basically
buy everything up
it's actually people say well you had
that big buyer coming it wasn't that
bullish and the market go higher well
you didn't get any follow-through
right there was no follow through even
though you had a big buyer come in
there's no zero follow-through right
there's zero trade here here it's just
Market just jumped up a few ticks and is
reverting back down that's why it's
bearish that's why it's bearish here
right that's why it's bearish here
and that's why this one is bullish this
is the opposite somebody came in here
sold it down really quick
and the market revert and went back up
right as you can see there's some nice
moves that come out of it all right
that's the buying and selling tail and
the last one I'll talk about for now is
the thin prints okay but let me just go
back to
BS get out of this mnq
so a thin print right
now you can adjust what you want as a
thin print
uh or it's in here so
the default is five if I set it to zero
I just want to see
bars
where there was Zero volume traded
either on the bid or the offer
internally inside the bar
because I know that this Market is
moving pretty quick right there's no
counter trade zero against 69 so when
the market was theoretically bid offered
here it was nothing to traded here
really what happened is somebody just
bought it up
um
you know two ticks through it here you
got zero here you got zero so you got a
strong seller just in a sense
sweeping through a price level right and
the market didn't even have time to sort
of fill that in and it's nice because it
gives you some nice levels you know when
they're there for the market to sort of
come back and and fill it it's kind of
an intro bar Gap if you will right you
can see here right if you imagine if you
just have an offered sitting in here you
know you got this bad structure so to
speak in the order flow at 74 and three
quarters you drop an offer in there
you know a couple tick stop three ticks
to get you know six ticks something
there are people that trade this on
longer time frames
let's take a look at a 15-minute chart
if there's any
even appearing
what day are we on here so let's go back
to
Friday okay
well I got it at zero if I were to
adjust it from zero up to maybe a higher
number
nine
here well there was one here when you
got another one here right you can see
it's acting as support all right this
one came in and filled the gap
you know sort of went a little bit lower
then it just you know going back up this
one's holding again this is at nine
depending on the market you're trading
um you know look at this one here this
one was beautiful
imagine this is a 15-minute chart okay
what was the volume that went through
there
right 15-minute chart is trading in the
EA minis how many thousands of contracts
in on a 15-minute period And even at
levels
is trading several thousand contracts
you can see 3.8 3.7 3.5 1.2 700 900 500
and zero
that's important information
all right and again you don't have to
use
zero depending on the type of chart you
want you know I was
set at nine maybe you want to set it at
okay and you can see here there's a zero
there 70 here
this one there was 100 it came right
down literally to that tick it went back
up
okay
it's late in the day there
um but you get the idea right that's the
importance of
using these tools again it's going to
vary on the market that you're trading
you know what sort of volume you want to
use
um
Etc okay so that's the main part of the
order flow is Trader now people say well
like you know
I want to see bar statistics right I
want to know you know they're used to
seeing volume and Delta numbers down at
the bottom so what you got to do for
that is you go to study
go to order flows this one called bar
statistics okay it puts it up here you
just drag it down with your mouse like
this
and again you can go to the layers
you can choose what you want to see bar
statistics right let me just
have a smaller
make this a little smaller right you
could choose these are the ones that I
chose right volume
Delta Max Delta Min Delta cumulative
Delta Delta percentage okay and you can
set the thresholds down here they're
already if you want to adjust what the
defaults are and these are important
because
so the first one is volume okay I like
to see the volume of the bar but then
the delta okay so there's going to be
times
where
let me just find it here
you know
certain volumes close next to each other
so let's for example let's go here
Delta threshold you know
95 percent
okay so you can see here I changed color
right it's just normal
red for negative Delta
green for positive Delta but if the
delta
closes
near its Max Delta or Min Delta I want
to know that
okay because
like in this bar right we came up here
to swing high now some aggressive
selling came in it was strong aggressive
selling
the final Delta closed right near our
mind Delta which is our strongest Delta
was in the bar
okay
and again you know it just gives you
that information just as down here right
markets going sideways now I know
aggressive buyers are stepping in our
final Delta 512 closed within 95 percent
of our Max Delta so it's telling me you
know what aggressive buyers have finally
taken control and you can see this
Market had a nice move up
Max Min Delta here
right set it to whatever you want I
think the default is set to 3 positive
or negative
let's say you want to set it to five
right so you can see here basically it's
just telling you that in this bar
or if it's a white number in the max
Delta that there wasn't much Max
it was either none or I mean zero or a
small
time period because it's a small volume
of four where aggressive buyers were in
control just as here they were never in
control zero zero zero
okay and it was it would be the same for
um aggressive sellers here right
zero Min Delta
right zero Min Delta and oftentimes
you're going to see it you know right
before a market starts to sell off or
rally here in this case sell off because
it's zero Min Delta all right I'll be
looking for some signs okay how do you
use this okay I got zero Min Delta
okay I'm gonna watch how it comes out of
here because I know that there was
strong aggressive buying right because
it maxed out those 173 although 173 is
not that strong I want to see okay maybe
let's see what happens if the aggressive
sellers start coming in and how
aggressive they're going to be then they
come in here in force minus 657 minus
144. Now Delta percentage threshold
default is set to 25
but again you can adjust it so you want
to set it to
you know 20 a slightly lower number
um you know again default is set to 25
so that's why
some of these numbers aren't appearing
but here set it to set it back to 25.
you can see 24 is not showing but 35
percent is
over here on this side
25.66 and what that's telling you is
basically the volume the Delta into the
volume for the bar
is quite strong right so if I know that
we got strong negative Delta of minus
1.4 overall volume for the bar is
4K
it's 35 percent of the bar's volume is
negative Delta because you know Mark is
still a good job of Distributing volume
buying and selling but there's times
where it's lopsided where you know in
the sense you have imbalance this is a
form of imbalance in the bar
you know and you want to be able to take
advantage of things like that when they
do appear you know sometimes you get big
moves out of them sometimes you get you
know smaller moves out of them
foreign
of using order flow is not just about
throwing everything
that's available onto your chart
you want to put the tools that are going
to help you
analyze order flow analyze the market
that you're trading Okay so
you know if
if most of us have watched the movie uh
Wall Street you know I I read a story
recently that the Gordon gecko guy
his character is based is inspired by
Jesse Livermore okay we all know who
Jesse Livermore was right reminiscence
of a stock operator and you know how did
he trade he was a tape reader So reading
the tape is not something that's just
new in the last 15 20 years what's new
is
how the data is analyzed right because
we've come a long way from looking at a
ticker tape all right you know those old
thicker tapes in the 1920s and 30s you
know you see the guy standing around in
trading room it's brilliant now that
um you know the software like go
charting can work on your phone I mean
in my opinion that's like
by putting a man on the moon but you
know it's a big advancement
in trading okay so you know you got to
uh take advantage of the tools that are
out there because you know there's still
a lot of people they
they don't use order flow
right they just they're content to
follow price and you know more power to
them some people make money with it but
majority
do lose money just following price right
you got to understand the intensity of
the buying and selling that's going on
all right so you know I got some time
here what time is it it's about just for
two o'clock I want to go through some
questions
um really quick here because you know I
don't want to keep guys on all afternoon
I see there's a lot of questions here
but let me just uh open it up uh really
quick but hang on a second let me uh
let me just put something back on the
screen here
give me one second here
okay I'm gonna put
this up here again these are all in the
chats right if you want the discounted
data plan
for
one month at uh go charting go to this
link here it's in the chat right there's
questions you know on your
if you were to expand your
go to webinar dashboard there's a chat
on the bottom okay it's all right in
there
but um
I'm just gonna go through some of these
questions really quick and
get you guys on your way it's it's a
Sunday
uh uh Nicholas uh in Greece uh hey
Daniel I'm doing good yes uh Stefan had
asked
Stephen rather there will be a recording
um how fast an internet do we need for
go charting for trading
it's again you know I
most of us
got decent internet connections I use I
look
at the footprint on my phone
um you know while my kids are playing
you know soccer right they got a soccer
game and they got practices in the
evening I sometimes I want to just check
in what the market is doing
I don't even know what my speed is on my
phone but uh honestly it's not like you
need a T1 line well see nowadays is all
you know I'll talk about Giga speeds but
honestly I think you could get as long
as you got a decent connection
you're fine right I've sat in the public
libraries just using the Wi-Fi there if
it's fine
um I don't think there's a minimum
requirement but you just need a normal
internet connection
um
Okay so
uh okay Israel I talked about how to log
in
and
yeah you know Deborah asked about crypto
yeah you know what I I posted a video
yesterday actually about crypto and it's
nice because you asked about Ripple xrp
now
you're probably gonna need the the
crypto data plan but as well there's
different exchanges as it says here the
one that I look at is coinbase I don't
know if you could well
yeah and this is where it gets tricky
with xrp right because I don't think
Americans well maybe now with the
lawsuit settled can can buy it again but
I know they stop people in the US from
buying it but here let's blow it up xrp
just give it a second
all right there's your footprint right
there
very fast right if you use ninjatrader
you know it's not fast like that
um Deborah I think the uh cost
let me see here
is you know it's under their Forex and
crypto uh plan
yeah actually you do need to subscribe
to the plan and it is not much
here crypto Forex crypto
just for the monthly plan it's like 20
bucks or something but that gives you
like the order flow charts silver flow
indicators
um they got a lot of other stuff on
there I've even delved into it it's very
robust uh
platform
um on what you could do but yeah
but you would need the Forex crypto plan
um
the queen says that the links are not
active they are let me just pop it up
I'm just clicking these out of the chat
that's for the the training course the
go charting trading course
um
this is the
page on
all the individual videos that I made
for the order flows Trader on goal
charting I want to try and get those up
on YouTube at some point this is the
user guide here
right I'm just clicking these out of the
chat but I'm going to email you guys all
these this is the the link we're signing
off but again I'm already signed up
if your first time signing up to go
charting just go through here
but um I'm gonna send you guys all those
links later
Deborah right now it's
a charting platform they do have some
Brokers set up not in the US I'm I'm
working with a couple of brokers in the
U.S uh some discount uh Futures Brokers
to get it because let me just show you
really quick
um
tradestation they just built in the
tradestation functionality so I believe
if you have trades station called
through trade station you can use it
they are they're working on their cqg
connection I'll check with them on on
where they are with it
um actually this team they're they're
very responsive in in terms of getting
things set up so
um you know usually you know software
companies they have timelines right they
have their road map and I've seen some
road maps for some software
that hasn't moved uh very quickly but
you know the cqg is a big connection
because any broker that accesses the
market through the cqg
um
feeds which is most of the Brokers out
there then you can be able to connect to
go charting on there but
um I'll be talking next week with some
brokers in Chicago about
getting go charting connected to them
and but the important thing is through
here right now this these are some
Indian
based uh companies
zeroda
um Etc but uh the Seeker G one is big
tradestation I believe they already got
the if you have a tradestation account
check or trade station but this one is
is Big which would allow it to connect
to anybody that connects to the markets
through train station through ckg
all right uh
let me see okay one thing to note right
now all right you can see the the data
plans here
is that CME
right now they only offer CME
data it's not CME CBO it's not CME Group
right which is CME cbot nymex comex
um right now it's just it's the CME and
it's and it's it's the main contracts
okay it's
uh they don't have it done here it's
again you know
down the line right they're new to the
US in terms of
um the market so most of us trade CME
stock you know trade the e-minis the mes
mnq
um and the currencies so
that's where that's our starting off
point so if you're on the Board of Trade
Trading bonds Ultra bonds anything like
that um it's not available yet but it is
in the pipeline to get it okay but we
just uh want to make sure it's working
fine on the other contracts and it is
it's working great
um
on these contracts you can see even down
here what's available you know they got
Market profile volume profile and all
symbols and Order flow on the most
liquid stocks right Apple things like
that Google Etc
uh sacally asks uh like to know about
your settings for
this is a long question here you know
what uh secondly I'm going to
make a note of this because that's not
an easy question to answer because he's
asking about what settings for like say
a bond four range or an e-mini 15 range
of course but you know what I'll
I'll message you just give me
tonight to get back to you four ranged
bonds
um 15 range ES
because that that's a good question
um
but we'll keep that one there
um someone asked about a template link
yeah I'm gonna I'll send out my template
uh this evening right after the videos
after the recording is done and rendered
um
I'll send it out but there are a few
people have been asking for it here I
can see uh
yeah of course you get
uh you can get info overload
um Nicholas asked is it worth
considering go charting if you already
bought the software for ninjatrader
eight and yeah it is
um because it's not right I mean right
now is for free but you know when we do
it a monthly payment you should always
have a backup of something you know for
whatever reason and you know the whole
point is
this is not necessarily to replace
the ninjatrader version at this point
right because again it's still
um you know I I do got to say a full
disclosure it does uh let me get my
chart back up here
um
one of the things that they're working
on it which I told them we got to get uh
going
um spying in the later part of this year
is
it only works on
time based charts
okay so I you know I know some of you
guys use range based charts right or
raincoat charts or you know it won't
work on you know this is a range based
chart right let me get back to it
an e-mini the footprint won't work on
there yet it's something that they're
working on
to develop Okay so
at the moment it's time based chart so
this isn't going to be a replacement for
the ninjatrader version yet it may be
down the line uh when we get everything
all our ducks lined up in a row
it can be but at the moment you know
there's still things that uh
need to be done because you know at the
end of the day go charting they're
they're not say new to the scene I mean
they're big in other parts of the world
but sort of the way Americans trade and
approach the market is yeah
they're they're really they got a lot of
different things that they look at you
know some guys
use
1587 tick charge 25 94 tick chart or
volume charts things like that
um you know a lot of traders in
different parts of the world just strict
the time-based charts so it's something
that we're working on right that we're
in the process of developing so just
bear that in mind
um Jose asked what's the three
indicators of order flow that you put on
for
minis I would use primary point of
control I would use uh thin prints and
probably Market weakness
out of go Trader I don't understand your
question Gary uh
yes this is being recorded
yeah Nicholas I mean that that is uh
Nicholas says
advantages or disadvantages being able
to connect From Any Given computer under
a web-based platform whereas ninjatrader
you have to install in a new computer
and use order flow and
you know even for me right sometimes I'm
all set to go Sunday night
right like it'll tell you Sunday but
I'll log in all right my computers are
shut down from Friday night until Sunday
I go in thinking oh that's okay all of a
sudden
I got all these pop-ups my machine ID
change I could do anything
to my machine no upgrades that I know of
the other things happen in the
background and all of a sudden it's like
everything is unregistered again and at
least for me
it's easy for me to update that but you
know if you're using indicators from
other people that link to your machine
ID you gotta you know contact this
vendor contact that vendor contact there
um it's a pain in the butt when your
machine ID changes because then you got
to enter your trading details you got to
enter your
um
Market you know your username and
password to you know access the market
data or your account even so it's a pain
in the butt in that sense whereas here
it's just web web-based platform and
uh it's easy to go
um
this is your last can you plot
a moving average of point of control
um
you know years ago
I thought of creating an indicator a
point of control
moving average so to speak honestly you
don't really need that there's it it's
it didn't add any value to my trading
you're better off just using view app
honestly is it would be very similar
um
you know and I I seen I was talking to
one guy about it I mean
a few months later he went out and
created an indicator on it it was was
selling it and but I said you know you
honestly you're better off using a v web
for that
um
okay uh Navi asks about my
screen yeah I'm sorry I apologize I do
have a high-res monitor so it might take
it might be a little hard for you to
watch
um
see uh Jose asked what will be the three
switches of the order flow that will put
you in for day trading yes yeah
Prominent Point of control thin prints
Market weakness uh Israelis can you
okay so this is an interesting question
Israel
says can we combine three or four
indicators to get signals like the buy
or sell
um well yeah I mean it's a form of
confirmation
and
I don't mind that you know where I sort
of
I can't say mind but you know where it
sort of goes off the track with some
Traders is you know sometimes again you
know people will put everything up on
their chart to all the different tools
all at once and say oh well this Bar's
got you know five different things of
order flow so it must be important but
you still got to put it in context of
the market right it's you know for
example right I it when I was in college
high school I used to go to the
racetrack a lot
um
then the horse races and I one of my
friends
he's one of these guys who mark up his
racing form a star here plus here check
their Dash here
and I'll be like what the heck are you
doing and you'd be like oh this is the
horse I got to bet because it's got
Stars got to check it's got a plus it's
got
um a one next to it Etc Circle this a
circle that
okay what
just because it's got all the the pluses
you know all the on all the checks or
whatever doesn't necessarily make it a
good bet or in this case a good trade
right you still want to put it in
context of the market okay because again
you could have the best whether it's
order flow or anything right if a market
is going sideways and
you get you know it's going sideways in
the middle of value
right right smack in the middle of value
for the day you get everything is
screaming bye
doesn't necessarily mean the Market's
going to go up right you still need the
market to sort of start making a move
right because
when the Market's going sideways
it's not moving right even though you're
getting some signals so you sort of want
to start putting it in context with
what's actually happening in the market
as opposed to just saying oh I got five
different indicators all firing off at
once
Raj asks uh
yeah you know rajes it's like any
indicator sometimes they get the wrong
signal and hence the trade gets stopped
out how can I filter these incorrect
signals do I want to wait for the next
bar to confirm yeah for me I always wait
for the next bar to confirm so for
example let me just open this chart up
more okay
foreign
in this bar right here right in the
middle right this is a trade I'd like to
take but it's not just because there's a
zero print I want to see this bar close
confirm that the zero print is going to
stay there the next bar to open and
start trading lower I'm fine to get in
short here
here
if it's going to give me a better
opportunity to be successful on the
trade I suppose other zero print right
here I gotta immediately get short and
the next thing you know this bar is
still trading and it goes back up and
fills in that zero print
okay
um because you know at the end of the
day no matter what method that you trade
right say you're getting
long
you get long you got no control over the
trade now you need everybody else that's
trading
it's also want to be getting long
okay so if nobody else is getting long
after you get long chances are Mark it's
not going to go up right then I'm gonna
say oh
Mike got long let's all get long no it
doesn't work that way they don't know
that I got long you know then they'll
say oh you know Mike a long way it
doesn't work that way right they other
Traders also have to have reasons on
their own when you're looking at order
flow however
it's giving you the signs that hey you
know what now we got a big Trader
getting short here because there's no
counter trade right you got zero volume
at this level and it hasn't come in to
fill in that area in that bar because
most bars majority of them 90 nine
percent
you don't get a zero volume print in the
middle of the bar but when you do that's
important to recognize
and you see look what happened right I
told you this is for order flow Market
sold off came back up literally one tick
through it and then sold off again
you know I saw this post some guy
on YouTube not YouTube
Facebook
these
talking he's selling this mentoring
program is
posting these trades one to
165 you know risk one tick to make 165.
honestly
there's nothing like that but you know
order flow is something that can give
you a low risk entry right now I'm not
saying you use one tick there's times
where you literally comes right back to
the tick imagine you get short here you
just got to take a couple ticks up a
stop a few ticks up
you know a point higher risking four
ticks to get what this is 79 and three
quarters
you know down to four and three quarters
which is here right even goes lower you
know you're risking one point to get
five
um
Futures only yeah for now future I'm a
Futures guy I trade futures
um Wilson I'm gonna send you over the uh
my my link
yeah Abby
um I'm gonna send it out this afternoon
the uh
I mean I don't know if I could even put
it
yeah
save I'll call this uh well
solitaire
webinar
and to continue
let's see here I don't know I'll put it
in the message here in the chat box
rather
access that I put it in the chat
so I don't know if that's going to work
but I'll play around with it but I'll
definitely send it out tonight can you
change the imbalance text color yeah you
can you just go through the settings
uh
well no let me get that back let me pull
that back no you can't change the
selling and balance from red or buying
and balance to Blue
um
okay
Manny asks how can you
a confident support trade with Prominent
Point of control sport or resistance so
let me just make sure I got point of
control on here
um
Prominent Point of control
the stone
for me the most the strongest
Prominent Point of controls are the ones
that the next bar doesn't trade back
into
because it's telling me two things one I
know this is now acting as my resistance
and two
the market is moving away from it right
it's trading away from this resistance
area
right it's like this one is traded back
into traded back into
okay trades right up towards it even
comes back up here okay then I got a new
one kicking off here right Mike it's
going up
then when you combine it with other
things right I've
talked about these actually I've talked
about how to use this
um
in my
yeah things like my master class um you
know you can start adding in imbalances
how they're appearing uh value areas
right one of my Strongest Ones you wrap
it around
the value areas
okay just really quick
this right right here you got your
Prominent Point of control it's in that
exposed value area it came back in right
so the trading trades back up to uh
bearish product control and sells off so
there's many ways to use it there's not
one way to use it okay
um let's go through some of these here
uh Gary had asked if he's got CME data
from nt8
do I need CME data from go training as
well yes you do
um you need to get the go charting the
data through go charting
yes uh Bob has asked a little too as I
demonstrate available under the ninja
Trader program of order flows yes
um
how secure is this company
it's scary they're a legit company
they're a big company in Asia just not
in the US
um so they're teaming up with me to sort
of bring it out to the US
support ftse 100 not the futures
okay let me go through a couple last
minute questions here
Manny asks uh
NES how to identify sideways Market
using order flow do you have any plan of
making one for us part of overflow
indicator
um
okay well the easiest way to identify a
market going sideways is if you're
looking at Value areas if the values are
pretty much overlapped one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten you
know 11 12 13 right
when I start seeing value areas that are
overlapped then I know it's a sideways
Market when I start seeing a gap between
a value area a low and a value area high
if Market's going down then I know it's
going to start to go down another way is
just look at point of control as a point
of controls are mostly
overlapping then that's a sign of
you know
basically a sideways market right here
you can see one two three four five you
know more or less at the same level
right even got three here another one
here two up here another two right down
here it's basically a sign of a sideways
Market okay that's the easiest way
um
yeah Navi um
if you use that link that's in the chat
you get the go charting data for CME at
the reduced price of just ten dollars
for the first month as opposed to 35 and
right now the the oracle's trader
platform
is free they're not charging you for it
eventually
um next month
you're going to see a little lock here
right that means you'd have to have a
paid version which you'd have to
subscribe through go charting not
through me through go charting on that
so
right now you can access it for free
see Jose asks about the master class
um
Jose I'll have to email you about that I
don't remember I don't have it handy off
my uh
stop my head but uh yeah in the master
classes
it was a live trading class and uh I'm
probably going to do one again in
September anyway but um
you know I usually like to do them once
a quarter for Traders but uh yeah I'll
send you some information about that uh
Jose but anyway guys I don't want to
keep you guys on all afternoon it's
Sunday you know we summer's coming to an
end thank goodness
it seems like forever for me
um you know I'm just happy to get my
kids back in school get them out of the
house off the gadgets and uh yeah enjoy
the rest of your day I'll send I'll be
sending out the link for the replay
I know because this one has gone about
an hour and a half almost
um I know go to webinar takes you know
they got a render it it's going to take
about an hour or no no rather since it's
over an hour it's going to take a few
hours but I'm gonna get that out to you
guys
um by this this evening so just be on
the lookout for it and I'm going to send
over the links again
um for you to sign up but they're in the
chat so have a great uh secondly I'll
I'm gonna dig out your email and I'll uh
I'll message you directly on that so I
have a great
rest or sacally rather I'm going to make
a video on on your question because you
know that's a question more on General
uh trading so I think that's something
that's going to be useful to a lot of
people as well
um
so have a great rest of your weekend
guys and I'll catch you guys
later bye-bye